breaking tonight President Trump warns
Iran Iran threatens America and moments
ago president Trump speaking to
reporters after returning to Washington
with strong words after Iraq votes to
expel US troops the president saying
quote we have an extraordinary expensive
airbase that's there it cost billions of
dollars to build long before my time
we're not leaving unless they pay us
back for it if they do ask us to leave
if we don't do it in a very friendly
basis we will charge them sanctions like
they've never seen before ever it will
make Iranian sanctions look somewhat
tame I think we can all agree classic
Trump there next quote so with Iraq
we've spent a lot of money in Iraq I
told you Iraq was the worst decision
going into the Middle East was the worst
decision ever made in the history of our
country Iraq by the way they didn't
knock down the World Trade Center that's
been very nicely proven but we went in
and we're there and we're pulling out
pulling out of a lot of different areas
with Syria I pulled out because I'm not
going to guard his border why should I
be guarding the border
they've got troops let them guard that
board has been under siege for thousands
of years they've been fighting on that
border more in that vein from me later
on as you will see we've got this and
more covered for you with the latest
news and the smartest analysis in a
moment we'll go to former Marine and
intelligence officer Congressman Mike
Gallagher Daria's plus here with me for
the hour jason Chaffetz Tommy Lauren and
Katrina Pearce and how good is that all
right happy new year everyone and
welcome to the next revolution I'm Steve
Hilton and this is the home of positive
populism pro-worker pro-family pro
community and of course for America also
in the show tonight more good news on
the economy more embarrassment for Joe
Biden and in loonie left we bring you
the strange death of the reasonable
Democrat how even the so-called
moderates in the presidential race are
way to the left of anything we've seen
before but first I want to lay out for
you how I see the issues with this whole
Iran situation over the past few days
we've heard a lot of superficial
simplistic and self-serving
grandstanding from the usual suspects
Trump hating Democrats and their Stooges
in the ruling class state media have
made complete fools of themselves it's
wildly inconsistent position
apart from one thing of course whatever
Trump does is by definition wrong one of
their favorite talking points for days
was that president Trump's action was
unconstitutional illegal blah blah blah
well that argument was destroyed this
morning by President Obama's Homeland
Security Secretary jeh Johnson if you
believe everything that our government
is saying about general Soleimani he was
a lawful military objective and the
president under his constitutional
authority as commander-in-chief had
ample domestic legal authority to to
take him out without an additional
congressional authorization the whether
he was a terrorist or a general in a
military force that was engaged in armed
attacks against our people
he was a lawful military objective I
suppose I should apologize for NBC's
sound problems there but you get the
point but the award for most humiliating
idiocy of the week probably goes to
Democrat Senator Chris Murphy who on
Tuesday after the US Embassy in Baghdad
was attacked but before the Soleimani
strike said that President Trump had
quote rendered America impotent just
hoping bad guys go away but when that
actually happened when one of the bad
guys indeed one of the worst guys in the
world did in fact go away as a direct
result of president Trump's action
Murphy criticized it literally
complaining about the fact that Salamone
had been taken out he wasn't the only
one ever since Donald Trump won the
election his opponents have lost their
minds and with it any ability to make a
coherent argument if Trump's for it
they're against it just look at their
policy pirouettes on the Middle East all
of it driven by anti-trump hate when he
pulled back from the Middle East it was
a disaster Trump has broken America's
solemn promise to those who sacrificed
so much on our behalf tired of Trump
wrapping himself in a flag in the
morning then abandoning our troops and
our values by the afternoon I would not
have withdrawn the troops and it would
not have drawn the additional thousand
troops are in Iraq yesterday on the
floor
354 members voted in a bipartisan way to
oppose the president's dangerous
decision to Syria right got that getting
out is dangerous so dangerous but wait
so is going in the president's decision
may add to an already dangerous and
difficult situation in the Middle East
we're going to end up in an escalation a
military escalation around the world we
appear to be without by the way I would
say without congressional authorization
entering into another Middle East war
they have taken a step that moves us
closer to war a step that puts everyone
at risk
they have no coherent position they have
no strategy they just have more of what
they gave us when they held the White
House appeasement weakness and
establishment predictability exactly
what kept us in these endless costly
stupid Wars but we've also seen
simplistic knee-jerk nonsense from the
isolation nuts
what's Trump doing he promised to get us
out of Wars not into them we shouldn't
be intervening abroad focus on our
problems back home you know this script
it's easy enough to luxuriate in
simplistic ideology and superficial
slogans but in the real world an
American president can't just disengage
from the world for the very obvious
reason that what happens in other
countries can affect us here that's why
we care about trade deals for example
they affect us here at home and yes
that's why we care about projecting
military power abroad the question is
not whether we should intervene
internationally but how America first
doesn't mean America alone nor does it
mean America stays at home it means
America's policies domestic and foreign
should be determined by what's best for
the American people and the isolation
nuts don't seem to understand that they
take a stand against any international
action even when it is in America's
interest next they'll want us out of the
Olympics because it's a foreign
competition
and speaking of international
competition the other bunch of usual
suspects who pooped off against the
soleimani striker the Europeans the
British the Germans and the French have
all expressed their grave concerns and
are calling for restraint
you bet they are they're still trying to
revive the rotten corpse of the Iran
nuclear deal which funneled billions of
dollars directly to Qasim soleimani to
fund terror and mayhem throughout the
Middle East the British are now in a
panic over their energy imports sending
Navy ships to God tankers in the Gulf
but that's because they've allowed
themselves to become dependent on energy
imports and unbelievably despite
estimates that fracking could help the
UK towards energy independence the
British government has just banned it
and that neatly brings us to the real
story here as we reported a few weeks
ago for the first time in history thanks
to president Trump's pro enterprise
agenda America has just become a net
exporter of oil and gas the truth is
that oil has been the driving force for
the West's involvement in the Middle
East for over a century
it drove British imperialism then
American imperialism and the inevitable
resentments that followed driven by the
energy imperative the West has tried to
remake and reshape the Middle East
creating nothing but a costly bloody
disastrous mess along the way the
establishment in Washington has cashed
in with some of the most obscene
corruption of the modern era Vice
President Dick Cheney pushing a
catastrophic invasion that put billions
of dollars into the pockets of his
former company Halliburton Vice
President Joe Biden's brother cashing in
two just like so many in the swamp in
the military-industrial complex in the
establishment who are addicted to
endless war in the Middle East now we
see the same geniuses in the swamp think
tanks and institutes for strategic
whatever gravely expressing their
concerns about how president Trump's
actions will hamper the prospects for
Middle East peace or the fight against
Isis or some other illusory goal what
planet are they on there are no
prospects for Middle East peace as long
as we are there we're never going to
defeat the ideology of Islamist terror
as long as all these countries are
basket cases and one of the main reasons
their basket cases is that our
preposterous foreign policy
establishment with
mental arrogance have treated the
middle-east like some chess game played
out in the boardrooms of Washington and
London they are a joke nothing they've
ever proposed has ever worked everything
has failed the West's involvement in the
Middle East has been a disaster from the
start
and finally with President Trump America
is in a position to bring it to an end
we don't need their oil and we don't
need their problems finally we have a US
president who gets that and wants to get
out that doesn't mean doing nothing it
means intervening only in ways that help
America it means responding to attacks
on Americans disproportionately as a
deterrent just as we saw this week
it means pulling out of missions that
are doomed to failure as we saw the
other month with Syria and it means
finally accepting that it's not our job
to fix the Middle East from afar that
trying to do so has infantilized the
whole region and the best thing American
can do to put the Middle East on a path
that leads to more democracy less
terrorism human rights and economic
growth is to get the hell out of there
while showing an absolutely
crystal-clear determination to defend
American interests with force wherever
they are threatened the real threat to
America is not Iran or anything else
coming out of the Middle East but China
the real strength of America is always
underwritten by a strong economy and
that must always be the priority I
believe President Trump understands that
and if he sticks to that strategy he
will have our support all right tell me
what you think at Steve Hilton X and an
X rev fnc